le département et antenne réunion vous
serez vance ya peu fiables
[Musique]
elles sont le symbole de l'amour de
l'élégance d'unique terre aussi les
roses se décline en d'innombrables
variétés mais l'une d'elles trouve ses
racines à la réunion la rouste bourbon
est une fleur ancien presque oublié le
département le jardin botanique et
l'association jardins créoles ont lancé
un projet de sensibilisation et de
valorisation
leur objectif retrouver dans les jardins
créoles les vestiges de ce patrimoine
local
[Musique]
bonjour madame comment allez vous
damabia merci ça va bien ok on nous
verra vraiment parler de votre jardin
avec des roses
on peut venir voir ce que vous savez
c'est à cilaos comme olic et françois
scientifique au jardin botanique de
mascarin entament leur chapeau trésor
alors vous savez on fait un inventaire
dans les jardins pour voir qui dans son
jardin encore des roses
voilà du temps longtemps l'objet de leur
quête me voici la rose edouard paul
terra ou edith de murat des variétés
connues sous le nom de rose de bourbon
une flore anciennes découvertes sur
l'île début militants il ya une
appellation roses anciennes c'est tout
l'hérault futur été créé avant 1920 les
gens n'ont pas forcément cette
connaissance des us et nous dire c'est
un rosier on sait qu'il est là depuis 50
ans c'est déjà un point intéressant trou
mais c'est pas des roses et vous avez
acheté ça c'est des moutures couvrirait
que l'on a planté lancé des briques un
appentis tombé dans l'oubli
c'est dans les jardins de passionnés que
la rose de bourbon pourrait avoir
prospéré en secret là on s'abstient
probablement aussi une autre rover
françois pour lever le mystère
les équipes les terence et prélève des
boutures on peut dire que son supérieur
ou inférieur un demi centimètre
supérieur et y est tombé vers l'arrière
ancien p on va lui mettre un numéro
donc après tour ces données là on va les
reprendre sur ordinateur pour mener à
bien ce projet
le jardin botanique compte beaucoup sur
la participation des habitants pour les
interpeller des brochures explicatives
ont été distribués pour pouvoir
s'introduire
dans les jardins c'est vrai qu'on va pas
comme ça allait à qui revient la mouche
ils gagnent trop minutes et honore donc
c'est un peu une course à la sherlock
holmes est un des indices
on veut dire s'il est quelque chose qui
ressemble un peu à sa fille et en
science peut être ça nous intéresse dans
une âme autres personnes à répondre à
l'appel sur cilaos suzanne 18 fait que
retraiter voue une passion à sebourg aux
fils des années je suis en train de me
pencher sur les roses l'histoire des
roses en particulier l'histoire des
roses grow bon ça fait à peu près vingt
ans que j'en entends parler j'aimerais
maintenant je suis complètement la
retraite ancien bandit sony j'aimerais
bien me documenter davantage et
apprendre à reconnaître une rose si elle
et bourbon ciel est pas
[Musique]
m
afrique7 qu'une rose qu'il y a un côté
un peu sauvageonne elle n'arrive pas à
se tenir à tenir sa tête la rose pense
toujours un petit peu la tige est trop
frêle pour la rose mais les heureusement
mon sens ce soit très délicate et en
plus parce qu'avant parfumée ce projet
de valorisation est soutenue par le
conseil départemental
objectif sensibiliser la population à ce
vestige du patrimoine local remettre ses
roses en culture et créer éventuellement
des filières professionnelles ou flâner
ya des roses l'objectif c'était bien sûr
de les répertorier et ensuite d'avoir un
jardin expérimental au jardin botanique
et pourquoi pas à cilaos ou au
département si nous découvrons une vraie
rose bonbon avec le département le
jardin botanique armes et flore et aussi
des pépiniéristes de la réunion que nous
souhaitons c'est relancer la filière
pour que nous puissions proposer aux
réunionnais des vrais rôles de bobos qui
font partie de notre patrimoine
intégrale de la réunion j'ai une fois
récupéré une partie des boutures et
ramené au jardin botanique à cent lieues
aura même des voussures d'occident si tu
veux les préparer il faut les replanter
rapidement une coupe au premier ne
d'accord et on combine lorsqu elles
fleuriront à nouveau et les
scientifiques auront tout le loisir
d'examiner et d'authentifier ces
prétendantes au titre de bourbourg qui
est très intéressant et en même temps
difficiles c'est que les gens et c'est
un derby l'histoire on sait pour ça
qu'après mon staff ou sur d
sur des experts extérieurs pour essayer
deux avant le nom exact on va ça
commença à bien trop là les différents
jeux sur l'année dernière voilà deux
cents ans que la rose de bourbon a été
découverte sur l'île
en cet honneur pour les journées du
patrimoine le jardin inaugurera sa
nouvelle revue qui abritera avec de la
chance nous tenons aux robots
[Musique]
c'est en 1817 que nicholas bray on
découvre sur l'île l'arrosoir à la suite
de croisement d'autres variétés
apparaissent donnant naissance à la
famille des roses de bourbon elle se
caractérise par une floraison gros
montants et un parfum délicat
le projet de valorisation de la rose
bourbon a pour but d'identifier les
rosiers restant curieux de les remettre
en culture pour accompagner l'émergence
le filières professionnelles pour
découvrir ce projet rendez vous au
jardin botanique de mascarin les 16 et
17 septembre pour les journées du
patrimoine
et pour fêter les 200 ans de la rolls de
bourbon
[Musique]